[Music]
and take a joke news
this guy can't take no jokes I never
take jokes submitted by noise' noise'
noise' an off-duty officer punches a
prankster in the face for playing a
practical joke if you could take a joke
do you also take a [ __ ] punch the
face yeah prank what'd he do to deserve
it this prankster he used a plastic
snake toy on a fishing line to scare
pastor Bryce and so there's one lady
that she was passing by and he threw it
at her and scared her and then that's
when this off-duty police ax that's in
this officer of flies there's no fly I
was sitting f duty police officer he
came up to this dude and just punched
him in the face well deserved I'm sure
you guys the clip I don't know that was
deserved it was like one of those
douchebag pranks there's a classic kid
thing it's like a nine-year-old kid
thing throw away that his grandma right
yeah like that he's got separated hair
and [ __ ] wearing a button-up shirt
and [ __ ] and he was like I'm doing
pranks today like it's like someone got
a whoopee cushion and the cop came over
and stopped him in the face I think a
whoopee cushion it's exactly right
here's the video children Isis reeling
her in reveals himself from behind park
benches I said I suppose you think
that's funny and he said well I do
actually
but Seanie constable andrew barrett is
off-duty and about to take is that a
grown man own hands briefly there's an
exchange of words then this moment of
madness as the officer lunges again well
that was the officer almost as if
nothing happened he just walks away
I will say this I will say this he was
off-duty so he's not a cop he's just a
regular person at one yeah a civilian
with anger problems a kid in the face
a regular person does that yeah but that
he's like it's okay
I would off-duty believe you should not
brought that up yeah yeah so he ended up
punching this team that I believe he was
about 18 years old and his dude the
off-duty cop is 44 oh you know what it
is is because she was an old lady like
it triggered something he was defending
her honor baby you know like he's like
[ __ ] with the old lady I guess maybe
that's why he got angry like she's fine
by the way like it's a really harmless
brain yeah there's a lower pranks out
there that deserve a little [ __ ]
beating but that's trying to figure out
on the wire I did that to my grandma
dude because she was like really scared
of snakes
Tyson throw so when she punched you the
baby what happened
well no she punches in the face that's
different oh yeah but the after he
please a police officer joining in where
I have a yeah maybe he said something
cuz they went off to the corner don't
said some [ __ ] like some words exchanged
I don't know what kid was getting smart
maybe he believed like he deserves a
baby he was like hey you should leave
this all day long he goes why [ __ ] your
wife can't believe [ __ ] my wife now I
have to punch you yeah of course he
takes everything literally was this
punch me in the face right okay
yes sir this off-duty cop he was later
convicted of assault occasioning bodily
harm
he was only fine four thousand dollars
for all of our Aussie friends can you
tell us what is occasioning meme hey you
want to point to a map and show me where
occasioning is because I'll believe it's
a country that's how [ __ ] smart we
are
so really I'm what does occasioning mean
I try to use the word of a collation
[Applause]
regulations give Appalachian waited for
the ambulance occasioning of the term
using a definition of assault
occasioning actual bodily harm okay well
you learn something new every day
we're dumb Americans our reasoning on
occasion occasioning you're not watching
like a [ __ ] news channel right now by
the way just to relax like up for a
Peabody Award the [ __ ] that we do our
titles is real news okay if you got the
facts correct and would have waited a
little longer
it's called just kidding news reason
Jesus anyway you're coming to us for
news it's over we're trying to dumb down
you guys told me this story and I went
to my friends I told and they told me I
was wrong
well you're stupid for coming to us for
some very truth but anyway yeah I have
you guys I saw this yourself would you
approach the köppen Big Chill he's just
a kid
no he's got anger problems see this is
what would happen see if I was like
walking by it and I saw him trying to do
that my what the [ __ ] man and I just
want to walk by but the fact is this guy
was at a distance no he saw it at a
distance and he felt like he had a walk
over a sock the kid in the face he has
anger issues he's yeah we think that
what happened to you since you have
anger issues as well so you say up you
would have done it have you ever bunch
anyone the face I haven't done it in a
long time not in the line
she's always asking for help it's the
opposite
oh she she bites you do not I have proof
for abuse oh yeah but I wasn't joke
right no she put me in a coma the
picture yeah and she didn't let me do it
back and we got in a fight what was it
I taught her a choke hold and she
decided we'll see it no not right now
it's gonna start a fight between this
later because the rule is if you do but
I don't accept it back because I'm a
girl what I don't like about it is how
you say I can do it back like all
gleefully yeah yeah yeah but that I to
get to do it do you agreed on pre no
anything I agreed upon it and why we
don't yeah to me I think it's unspoken
word it's kind of like the conduct of
warfare between way between boys and
girls it was all about nerds who have
read sons ooh yeah I mean like it's kind
of like it's like almost like you got a
basketball you brought it over and
you're playing in front of me and then
you invite me to play and then you leave
the court that's how did you meet with
the basketball that's how it felt I
can't learn how to do a choke hold on
you cuz you're like oh let me teach you
how to defend yourself because you're a
little girl and then you want to [ __ ]
do it back on me and actually choke me
out like this if you own a gun you have
to get shot by one exactly with you
exactly they're soft gun BAM if you own
a sword you have to get stabbed by one
as well you see the scars on his body
people always say this though they're
like well how come it's okay for her to
do it to him but not okay for him to do
it to her just think about it for a
second like of course it's not okay for
him to do it to her yeah
no no I'm not talking really chokehold I
don't only care about that I'm talking
about talk about like [ __ ] like
violence in general everything like it
it's all the arguments from now and to
beyond if you're in public and a crazy
girl like tries to swing at you you're
not allowed to punch her but you are
allowed to choke the [ __ ] [ __ ] up so
she turns [ __ ] blue and pale I just
run but I never struck you though I just
hug the [ __ ] out of your throat you kill
him with kindness yep that's key that's
very key
I don't know whatever Casey and I play
fight like you'll always need me in the
stomach between boys that's kind of
crossing a lot like reaction I'm like
you can't do that you gotta control
yourself he's like what I'm a war
machine ha I'm a war machine I'm trained
to kill I never play a fight with Mariel
anymore anymore she sticks to heal in my
teeth like that no there's no plate like
we're in bed am I to kick your balls no
she we almost broke up because of that
[ __ ] because she kept on picking my
balls was just like a fun spot to hit I
was like you kicked me in the balls
it's like me shocking you directly in
the face full force is that okay she
goes something she's never experienced
before of course not
she thought she thought the ball was
like haha buddy like that it's like it's
like why is she goes I've always done
this maybe you should stop I'm your
boyfriend not a rapist
like there's a difference yeah she
better I swear to god she better be
hitting each other people in the balls
he should be like retribution for me the
difference is merely just our
physicality like period it just work
we're babe way bigger we're stronger yes
it's true that way bigger so that's why
he wanted it to be equal
yeah was cuz with crazy women but you
got a mirror that wants to kick you in
the balls I have my wife who doesn't
even play a fight she please stab me she
was okay she Kaiser
no she potentials a knife in a hash you
terrorists most girls would come up and
go Tico Tico and she's like walking by
her like I don't know where she learned
that from sometimes she's like pinkies
nipples anything she does that she
actually moves like that
I mean obviously a girl ears I'm doing
it
I've done it back to her when she
pinches my nipples I've opportunity to a
senator but hey she's gonna do it I'm
gonna do it back I like reaching for it
I never quite do it I reach for I did it
one time I just went for it
that's a man with respect right there
he'll pretend
he won't actually try to do it cool I
try to come under as much as I can
though that's where the payback every
month I have a jacked off in four days
nikki is not like our girlfriends so she
does I try to come on her as much as I
can get away with I can't I can't sit
here against the dudes I got a [ __ ] I
gotta redeem myself so thank you [ __ ]
you in the nipple if you like that's
funny I'm not gonna masturbate for six
days you're in for something I'm like
I'm like honey we get we're going to
Costco she's like why and I'm like this
we're getting some clear eyes gonna need
a big bottle hello everybody
if you liked the video make sure that
you guys leave us a thumbs up because if
not I'm gonna find you where you live
and I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you
with you other than that you know
there's like more videos up there bro
[Music]